ein toter und sieben verletzte in einem
oberpfälzer restaurant und tranken die
gäste vergifteten champagner es fing
alles so schön an die entkorken sich
eine flasche champagner um den auftritt
ihres freundes im fernsehen zu feiern
und das hier das ist das letzte foto
bevor harald georg z starb knapp über 50
jahre alt war alt das hat er gepostet
ertrinkt im restaurant la vita in weiden
stößt auf den kumpel an mit freunden und
das endet dann so auf eine vita der name
des logos und dahinter steckt eben dann
ein champagner sausen drama sieben
menschen vergiftet verletzt ein mann
georg z stirbt an diesem schrecklichen
abend nachdem sie sich eine drei liter
flasche aufgemacht haben das wissen
schreckliche szenen gewesen sein die
sich dort abgespielt haben in diesem
restaurant la vita die gäste hatten
schaum vor dem mund 3 liter champagner
haben sie bestellt wollten eigentlich
feiern anstoßen und harald ghz der nah
an den größten schluck und kurz darauf
endete das ganze für ihn im krankenhaus
und dann auch tödlich während andere
gäste mit schaum vorm mund mit krämpfen
mit anfällen nicht wussten was los wir
schalten jetzt genau dorthin wo das
ganze passiert ist ja ans restaurant la
vita zu unserem bild reporter jörg
völkerling der dort ist jörg sag uns
einmal an diesem montag nach diesem
schrecklichen abend im restaurant la
peter weiß man schon was genau dort in
der flasche champagner drin war
tatsächlich das weiß die polizei auch
wenn sie es offiziell noch nicht bekannt
gemacht hat nach informationen von bild
befand sich eine droge in dieser flasche
wohl ecstasy mdma stoff und zwar 100
gramm das 1000 fache einer normalen
konsum einheit wie das in die flasche
gekommen ist das ist jetzt gegenstand
der ermittlungen es muss natürlich auch
geprüft werden ob die geschädigten das
selber schon vorher zu sich genommen
hatten das ist aber sehr
unwahrscheinlich
die gute nachricht an diesem morgen
lautet es ist niemand mehr in
lebensgefahr
es bei einem opfer dass es schlimm genug
geblieben
das ist
georg betz aus frei ein 52-jähriger
projektleiter von einem getränkeabfüller
apfel hersteller der für asien und
pazifik zuständig war der auch sonst
sehr viel in der welt herum gestattet
ist viele fotos gepostet hat sich beim
golfspielen und dessen stammkneipe das
hier war das la vita und er war mit
freunden hier am samstagabend er hat
sich gefreut nachdem in bayern endlich
die sperrstunde die korona bedingte
sperrstunde bis 22 uhr aufgehoben war
weggefallen war dass man endlich mal
wieder länger feiern gehen konnte und
dann hat er mit einem freund mit dem ich
gestern gesprochen habe der war in
mexiko und den hat er um 21 46 noch
dieses foto bzw dieses video geschickt
wie er mit seinem kumpel im la vita mit
aperol spritz anstößt und das tragische
ist der anlass dieser partie war ja
diese rtl datingshow take me out wo ein
regensburger kandidat sozusagen
versuchte mit damen anzubandeln markus g
heißt dieser kandidat die show
aufgezeichnet wurden und markus g war am
samstagabend mit bei dieser partie dabei
er hat mit seinem freund georg z von dem
vergifteten champagner getrunken die
flasche eine doppel magnum flasche moet
chandon zum preis von über 500 euro aber
es waren alles offenbar auch gutbetuchte
gäste die sich ab und zu auch mal was
leisten wollten und markus g ist
ebenfalls mit schweren verletzungen ins
krankenhaus gekommen
wie gesagt die situation für die
rettungskräfte in der nacht auf sonntag
war so dass wirklich einige mit schaum
vor dem mund auf dem boden lagen ich
habe auch von krankenschwestern gehört
die einen sehr chemischen geruch
beschrieben haben bei den geschädigten
und die mussten dann corona bedingt auf
krankenhäuser im ganzen umland verteilt
werden teilweise wurden die notaufnahmen
gesperrt weil man der nacht auf sonntag
zunächst annahmen die opfer seien mit
blausäure kontaminiert dann konnten die
notaufnahmen keine anderen patienten
mehr aufgenommen werden das hat sich
dann später als nicht richtig
herausgestellt aber wie gesagt die
staatsanwaltschaft weiden ermittelt
jetzt im moment noch wegen fahrlässiger
tötung ob daraus mehr wird ob da ein
kapitaldelikt eventuell dahinter steht
das ist jetzt noch gegenstand der
ermittlungen dafür ist es einfach noch
zu früh ja da ist ja auch mit dem bruder
des opfers gesprochen was konnte er dir
berichten von diesem amt
ja er hat mir berichtet dass diese
partie eigentlich in regensburg
stattfinden sollte da gab es aber in der
familie es wird ein todesfall so dass
man das dann sozusagen schicksalhaft
hier nach weiden verlegt hat es kamen
dann gäste aus regensburg aus kam hier
aus weiden aus dem landkreis schwandorf
die hier alle feierten und offenbar
schon sehr früh den abend hier auch
gemeinsam begonnen hatten
georg z ist zwar ein lebemann sein
lieblingsgetränk war offenbar auch moniz
aber
niemand der jetzt irgendwie mit drogen
in kontakt gekommen ist also ich habe
mit seinem freund der momentan wink
mexiko welt gesprochen wer gesagt nie
und nimmer hätte der irgendetwas sind
diese eine solche berauschende substanz
freiwillig zu sich genommen und
der bruder hat mir also geschildert er
war selber gestern zur vernehmung lange
bei der polizei man hat ihm auch im
unklaren gelassen was jetzt eigentlich
das für eine substanz gewesen ist er hat
mir aber noch geschildert dass sein
bruder wohl noch versucht habe nachdem
er den größten schluck von diesem
vergifteten champagner zu sich genommen
hatte versuchte noch auf die toilette zu
robben aber für ihn kam jede hilfe zu
spät er ist wohl noch in der nacht gegen
0.30 hier im la vita hinter mir
verstorben dramatische schilderung von
jörg völkerling von unserem bild
reporter dort am tatort vor dem
restaurant la vita müssen wir uns noch
einmal vorstellen da sollte es eine
bunte champagner sause geben und am ende
dieser partie nachdem man dort diese
drei liter flasche geköpft hat sind
sieben menschen vergiftet sieben
menschen verletzt und ein mann eben tod
nach dieser champagner sause wir wollen
jetzt tatsächlich mit dem mann sprechen
der dieses restaurant verpachtet mit
harald rippe mit ihm sind wir verbunden
herzlich willkommen bei bild live verrät
jürgen blum schildern sie uns einmal
einfach wie haben sie diesen abend
erlebt ja es war irgendwie ein bisschen
komisch denn ich habe mir überlegt
abends noch ins la vita zu gehen weil es
bei wie um die ecke liegt ich wohne vier
häuser entfernt
und jetzt eines der häuser die ich
besitze ich verbracht habe und ich heute
abends noch eine kleinigkeit essen und
wieder gehen habe mich aber dann für
eine annäherung entschieden bin nach
hause und habe dann irgendwann um 00 30
die ersten blauen lichter gesehen und
haben natürlich aus dem fenster geschaut
und gedacht ist ein ganz normaler
einsatz das vielleicht irgendwas
passiert ist aber beim bund sondern mehr
fahrzeuge und am schluss machen uns 15
und 20 fahrzeuge polizei feuerwehren und
zwar noch die stadtwerke vor ort und es
wurde alles großräumig abgesperrt die
einsatzkräfte dann erklärt weil ich
natürlich nach gefragt habe was der fall
ist und was man
jetzt ist der bild kurz weg herr deppe
vermutlich kommt karten anruf reihen bei
ihnen wir verbinden uns gerade noch mal
neu während wir diese bilder von dem
blaulicht einsatz dort am abend das war
ein riesiger einsatz in weiden in der
oberpfalz noch mal sehen das hat apple
ja gerade aus seiner sicht geschildert
und von unserem bild reporter jörg
völkerling haben sie das gehört das war
ein so großer einsatz man hat gar nicht
natürlich gewusst was ist dort drin
gewesen in dem champagner dass man
zunächst auf blausäure getippt hat
daraufhin konnten keine weiteren
patienten aufgenommen werden als
vorsicht in der notaufnahme dort in
weiden in der oberpfalz und die traurige
bilanz ist eben ein toter sieben
verletzte nach dieser schampus nach dort
in weiden und mainz jetzt harald rippe
der verpächter des restaurants wo das
ganze passiert ist schön dass sie bei
uns sind haben sie irgendeine erklärung
dafür wie das gift wie die drogen in den
champagner kommen konnten ja es ist
wirklich sehr merkwürdig es gibt
gerüchte der herren der tat waren
natürlich gefällt davon dass jeder hier
geschichten erzählt hat und jeder aus
irgendeiner ecke was gehört haben möchte
ich habe auch mit meinen rechner
gesprochen und verständlicherweise am
boden zerstört die bedingungen die das
ganze lokal eigentlich mit betreibt uns
gute idee ist die hat sie auch beim
champagner getrunken und sie war eine
der ersten
und auch auf dem boden lag und ich wir
heute weiter entfernt habe ich noch die
scheiben gehört und das hat ausgesehen
als hätten sie epileptische anfälle
haben im ganzen körper gezittert und das
konnte man ihn und vor allem jetzt
konnte man auch hören das war schon sehr
sehr erschreckend
wer hat es
besteht natürlich auch
verständlicherweise unter schock kann
mir das auch nicht erklären und die
flasche wurde so auch seine aussage vor
ort geöffnet die bar original
verschlossen also wie er konnte nicht
vorher repariert worden seien oder war
geöffnet und es soll ja auch ein video
geben das habe ich allerdings nicht
gesehen das habe ich nur gehört von der
zeremonie wie man diese flasche geöffnet
hat und wie das dann passiert ist sehr
seltsam aber seine aussage nach sind
auch die leute innerhalb von 23 minuten
wirklich reihenweise umgefallen und
haben diese vergiftungserscheinungen
gehabt das entspricht dann natürlich
nicht davon dass champagner gekippt war
oder dass etwas bei der abstellung
passiert ist sondern das muss mir wie
ich gegen die mauer stift was auch immer
gewinnen aber ganz ehrlich in diesen
dramatischen stunden nach diesem
schrecklichen vorfall da am abend ich
kenne die restaurant nicht ist das in
weiden bekannt dass dort ecstasy über
tresen gehen könnte möglicherweise das
dort regelmäßig drogen konsumiert werden
oder überhaupt nicht nein also überhaupt
nicht es ist ein ganz normales
speiselokale und es gibt einen bereich
mit einer bar vorne wo das ganze
passiert ist wo ich mich auch gerne
aufhalte und werden auch heute die
hessen haben die anfragen nach essen
noch ein schluck nehmen noch ein getränk
zu sich nehmen ein bisschen feiern aber
das sind hier trugen im spiel sind wir
sind in der nähe der grenze zu
tschechien und somit gibt es im kleinen
grenzverkehr mit drogen also ganz
natürlich hier schon ein thema in beiden
lastwagen auch immer mal wieder
auftauchen aber dieses restaurant gibt
es seit mittlerweile zehn jahren und
aber noch nie irgendetwas was mir
bekannt werde so etwas passiert werden
sagt harald rippe und er könnte uns über
diesen abend berichten über diesen abend
an dem freunde vielen dank denn einfach
nur feiern wollten eine flasche eine
magnumflasche champagner öffnen wollten
und das endete mit sieben verletzten und
einem toten des giftes prallte offenbar
aus der champagnerflasche passiert ist
das ganze in weiden im restaurant la
vita